so you got your second page there as
hopefully you excited you're familiar
with by now or not starting well and
truly there are two pages that are
relevant to the mathematics to the to
unit course and then the last page is
the extension one page so I just want to
point this out for you right now because
I look all of this stuff that you now
actually know about now I just have a
look under integrals right we know what
integrals are we've been using this
language for a while now how many of
those integrals have we actually dealt
with in class underneath that direct
heading it's just the top one that's it
we haven't touched the integration or
differentiation of exponential functions
log functions all of this is trig okay
but then after that oh you should
recognize this right we've done this
this week so what are these things the
giveaway are those squiggly equal signs
right so we can use the trapezoidal rule
or Simpsons rule to approximate any
integral we like not a trick question
even though it's straightforward what
does the trapezoidal rule use what kind
of shape didn't use to approximate an
area what is use it uses a trapezium
right now more tricky question less
trivial what shape does Simpsons rule
use it uses a parabola which is why you
get so much more accuracy because of
course parabolas can be curved right now
don't forget what that means is you can
approximate any integral with these and
we know some integrals to do with same
volumes right now a classic sort of
harder to you the question is
approximating a volume using trapezoidal
rule and a lot of people's brains just
kind of fizzle out because they're like
huh it's a list of volume how do you how
to use one of these right well it will
do any integral including one that comes
from a volume okay all right now I just
want to point out good we know some
integral stuff here but interestingly
the thing I want to highlight today is
not on the integrals it's over here on
the last page and a binomial theorem
okay now binomial theorem we looked at
this pretty early last year I'd like you
with me to write down you see there's
three things in this inequality three
things that are all equal to each other
what's the difference between a second
of the third thing have a look at them
closely what's the difference
yeah the powers have been switched
around which is their way of saying you
know how this is going to be from
Pascal's triangle right
the Pascal's triangle just like a
binomial expansion is symmetrical okay
so doesn't matter if you start with the
A's as bigger numbers and the B's is
smaller numbers or other way around
you'll get the same extension either way
okay the for the purpose is what we want
to do now I just want you to write the
first two can you write this part of the
equation and then we're going to talk
about it
okay now if you have another color there
that'll be handy just go this now okay
right how many look at this thing I
wonder if you've gotten to the point now
where unlike when you first looked at it
and you thought oh my goodness what is
this thing I wonder if you've gotten to
the point where you can tell me about
every single symbol on this pit on this
you know equation and say I know exactly
what each of these means I think you
should be there let me help you remember
okay what is this thing
over here on the left hand side this a
plus B we have a special name for this
we call it our it's got two things we
call this a binomial right it's not just
any sum it's a two two terms son so it's
a binomial when you raise it to a power
it'll expand out to this long awful
thing right so rather than write out the
whole law awful thing each of the terms
that you get is quite similar there's a
term you get from Nck in occasion tation
with all the factorials and stuff inside
that there's a term with the A's and
then there's a turn with the B's yeah
when you have a look at these powers one
of these powers is climbing up and one
of them is climbing down yeah and
eventually they swap places now the
thing I want you to focus on is this
this guy here this itself also has its
own name what's it called
this is called Sigma notation right
named after the Greek letter that it's
in okay now when Sigma notation was
invented okay people thought really
carefully about what should go into it
because it's kind of doesn't really look
like anything else that we've ever used
right now particularly on ask two
questions of simulation firstly why is
that there k equals it's not a
rhetorical question and put yourself in
a position of the people who are
inventing some notation to try and write
this thing out but not write out the
whole long thing because mathematicians
famously lazy why do we put K equals
there hmm now we have seen like limit
notation go underneath things like this
like limit as n approaches infinity or
as actual equals zero or something like
that but this is some
been quite different isn't it what might
be lost if I didn't have the K equals
there what might be lost hmm why is the
laughing people like on that is all
about numbers there are no numbers on
the port right if you like oh well wait
look there it is there's one number okay
now you've got to work out where that
number is going to go you've got to work
out where zero goes and one and two and
three and then all the way up to M okay
but without anything here where is it
going to go like you've got so many
pronumerals here to choose from there's
not a clear explanation of where it goes
and so we say K equals or r equals or x
equals in order to tell you well when
you change the number where is that
going to go into it goes into here here
and here
and not any of the other pruning rules
does that make sense okay now I'm gonna
ask the question in Reverse when what
cake was down the bottom but there's no
K equals at the top a lot of rhetorical
question why not like if we bother to
put down the bottom why haven't we put
it at the top also because they're both
about the same thing
staring empal come a redundant right
redundant means like it's not necessary
you don't get any extra information by
saying K equals zero down here and K
equals n up there because if you started
putting numbers into K you're just going
to keep on doing it indicate doesn't
change right so that's why this notation
is trying to be as bare as possible and
put down the the minimum amount of
information required okay now the reason
why I'm highlighting that is because
when you have a look at something like
this
you can write this down if you like the
integral notation is clearly related to
Sigma notation write clearly related in
fact they probably would have used the
Sigma if it hadn't been taken already
because what they're doing is they're
summing right they're adding things up
now it's clearly related because number
one it's same letter just a different
language alphabet but secondly do you
see how the thing that we've been
focusing on here it appears here as well
it means something of a bit different
like here it's just whole numbers 0 1 2
3 4 here it's like three and thirty
point one and three point two and all
the infinite number of real numbers in
between right but it's the same idea for
start here and in here yeah so I hope
you see in parallel